just like that Springs upon us just as
it typically brings forth New Beginnings
spring also comes to us with a great
offering of anime goodness just as we'll
get a lot of anticipated sequels to
popular franchises we're also going to
be getting a handful of new anime for
those newly getting into the medium it's
going to be an exciting season and I
can't wait to talk about it so what are
the top 10 most anticipated anime this
spring 2023 is my take on the topic so
Arizona
[Music]
how about starting off with something
that's quite relatable it seems that the
topic of insomnia has become the hot
subject in anime main characters I mean
it's not common but it's interesting
that it's happened twice already with
Call Of The Night a year ago however
this title leans a little less towards
the supernatural having it served more
as a backdrop a way to start the story
that puts our main characters isaki and
Gunther together trapped in the
supposedly haunted astronomy club
Observatory the two opposites form an
unlikely friendship they bond forged and
symbolized by The Observatory the two
try to help each other cope with their
issues an endearing couple in a romantic
Slice of Life pretty much a good formula
for something that might as well be a
feature film it just has that kind of
vibe to me you know you can't help but
root for them as they try their best and
grow with each other and the romance and
drama are of the right dose so it's not
too overwhelming or convoluted it's a
simple romantic Slice of Life that I
feel leans more towards the more mature
audience but it's one that can be
enjoyed by just about anyone
foreign
dead Mount death play comes in at number
nine
[Music]
tell me if this reminds you of something
towards the end of the climactic
showdown between the legendary hero and
the great Necromancer The Necromancer
finds himself forced into his final
trump card reincarnation magic one that
transports him across space and time
before waking up as the boy polka
shinomia however things aren't all
sunshine and Rainbows in the human world
though Parker may have lived to fight
another day but he now has to contend
with the trappings of the human world
I'm talking the Yakuza the underworld
and a cat and mouse game involving the
police it's time for reverse is a guy
goodness and it doesn't get any Tighter
and more intense than this dead Mount
death play as far as the source material
is concerned employs a rather nice
storytelling technique parallel
perspectives on a single storyline
pretty much similar to bakana or
durarara if you've seen those shows I
think this gives the show a Unique Edge
in giving more light to its events and
characters while it does have a weakness
of slowing the main narrative down a
little bit I also like how he gives some
added complexity and effort that you
don't typically see in an isakai title
so if you're looking for a new Sakai
title to watch then you should
definitely give this one want to spin
[Music]
we then have our first series
continuation in the mix konosuba
explosion on this wonderful world
[Music]
no it's not the sequel that people have
been waiting for but more gone are still
by an anime form is always a welcome
sight isn't it one of the more popular
slapstick Issa guide titles out there
konosuba has forged a name for itself
with its emphasis on parody and comedy
and its boldness in embracing the
degenerative aspects of the genre all
while being a ball of good over-the-top
fun Mega mint has become one of the if
not the most iconic characters in the
main cast so I wasn't surprised that the
anime team decided to give this prequel
spin-off a shot this tells the story way
before consumer's death and subsequent
arrival to this wonderful world so
instead the spotlight Shines on our
favorite explosive Duo Mega Min and
Union as it recounts their days in casts
on the various Misadventures that they
got themselves into including Mega means
road to obtaining her signature skill so
whether you're a fan of megumin or not
the new spin-off is a great addition to
the ever-growing konosuba library fans
are going to enjoy this and who knows
maybe people who aren't too much into
the main series will also find something
that they like in this prequel that's
what the No Game No Life movie did as
far as my personal anecdotes can tell
[Music]
me
going back to a new series now we take a
look at marshall
[Music]
is
in a society ruled by magic Mash sticks
out like a sore thumb with him having no
Proficiency in Magic at all the people
decided that he has to be purged so
running away for his own Survival Mash
begins training training so hard in the
one thing he's actually proficient at
physical strength so with this gift he
looks to make his mark on the world as a
Divine Visionary and existence so
powerful that the world will be forced
to acknowledge Him and the start of his
journey brings him to Eastern magic
Academy it's not going to be an easy
Journey going up against the elites and
the best of the best with his fists that
can compete against the most powerful
types of magic and the grandest goal in
mind there's nothing that's gonna stop
him the synopsis at one point gave me my
Hawkeye flashbacks but in reality the
series is more of a one punch man type
thing while being set in a Harry
potter-like setting quite an intriguing
mix if you ask me but it just works and
it's really good at being the Heavenly
blend of an engaging action fantasy
story and a plain old parody series it
does take a while to pick up but once it
does I easily got hooked into following
the story as an anime I hope it does the
same to you especially if you're a fan
of these kinds of underground stories
[Music]
hell's Paradise is up next
if you've been watching videos on my
channel for a good while now you know
how high I am on this show Avalon called
hell's Paradise one of the most
anticipated new anime to come this 2023
and it turns out that we won't have to
wait too long to see what the buzz is
all about yeah I've had some misses on
my pre-season predictions but I think
that as far as the general action
adventure loving side of the fan
Community is concerned it would be
really hard for hell's Paradise to be a
Miss after all it does have a lot of
things going for it a thrilling survival
plot a perilous Adventure full of stakes
and a very charismatic Immortal
protagonist hell's Paradise is pretty
much all of the elements to make a very
popular action-adventure series so
there's a reason it's one of the biggest
upcoming jump adaptations that has got
everyone on the edge of their seats it
all comes down to execution but if we've
come to learn anything about mudba and
their latest hits this one is gonna be
one hell of a banger if you want to
learn more about the premise however and
what I think of it you can go back to
one of my previous seasonal videos which
I'll be putting up on the upper corner
of the screen
[Music]
foreign
in the meantime why don't you hit that
like button and subscribe to the channel
you'll get more content like this and
you'll be helping the channel out and
growing let's work together and make
this one of the biggest anime channels
on YouTube brief change of pace after
the break let's take a look at oshinoko
[Music]
foreign
idle fans can be a wild bunch there's
little that can match their passion for
their favorite pure maidens and the
gynecologist Gordo amamiya is no
exception that's why finding his
favorite Idol I hoshino as his patient
is a dream come true despite promising
the pregnant Idol a safe delivery he
finds himself being the unfortunate
recipient of an untimely death thus
begins The Reincarnation however instead
of waking up in a fantasy world like
we're accustomed to Goro finds himself
reborn as aquamarine hoshino you heard
that right he suddenly found himself as
eyes newly born kid still a happy ending
for our idle fan but he'll soon learn
that the idol life may not be the dream
that aspiring girls thought it would be
in a road paved with thorns he looks to
protect I smile with the help of an
unexpected Ally oshinoko really looks
promising the whole truth behind Idol's
premise isn't anything groundbreaking as
I'm pretty sure a lot of us already know
about the Thorns that plague the
industry however execution is what
matters here and from what I've read
oshinoko really tackles the topic in an
enjoyable and endearing way it's
definitely not all sunshine and rainbows
but it also carries its self in a style
that can easily catch any Fan's
attention due to its emotional stakes
and lovable characters a definite
recommendation from me especially since
it's written by the same person who
wrote Gago yasama
[Music]
ranking of Kings treasure chest of
Courage is up next
[Music]
Against All Odds ranking of Kings has
become a sleeper hit that has serious
considerations for being 2021's anime of
the Year actually come to think of it
there's been quite a lot of them last
2022. Bocce The Rock being the biggest
one of all just felt like I'd like to
mention that because ranking of Kings
did spend half of its run in 2022. you
know it's just one of those shows that
came with little Fanfare before
exploding onto the scene thanks to a
couple of excellent decisions in
execution thanks to the success of
ranking of Kings a continuation is to be
expected but for now we'll have to set
up with a Side Story series as at the
time of this writing though there's not
much information but more ranking of
Kings is always welcome the first
season's anime staff make their return
and given their excellent work the first
time around I'm expecting a lot of good
things for this one with no manga to
base the plot around let's see how they
handle an original story this time
people absolutely loved ranking of Kings
when it was airing so this original
story might be a sign for you to go
watch it don't judge it by its
appearance and overall atmosphere you'll
come out having watched a series that
you'll never regret having picked up
starting out the top three we have the
much awaited return of Dr Stone
[Music]
doctor
stands back with its third season and it
looks like it's gonna be amazing as
usual now that the stone Wars have been
dealt with senko turns his sights on the
next major Quest finding the answers to
the petrification that kick-started the
entire plot however in order to begin
this Grand Journey he has to First build
a ship and find a captain even if he's
not the most pleasant person to be
around of course that's all covered in
the TV special Dr Stone Ryu sui so you
should go and check that out as this
third season serves as a continuation of
that Dr Stone's third season aptly
titled New World Chronicles what happens
to senku and the group as they take to
the season look for the fabled treasure
chest left by biakuya a whole new
frontier away senku as they face dangers
and a civilization with a Sinister past
all part of the package for a
breathtaking glimpse of world Beyond if
you enjoyed the first few seasons of Dr
Stone you'll love this one as well it
expands on the already interesting world
of Dr Stone also we know it's about time
they start tackling the overarching plot
of the series right don't miss this one
if you're a fan of the series
[Music]
Demon Slayer is back and it's at number
two
Demon Slayer may have lost its 2019
luster but make no mistake it's still
one of the big and popular action anime
out there all I said is that it would be
hard to match how he took the World by
storm back in 2019 with the series and
its subsequent Infinity Train movie
still Demon Slayer fever is well and
alive and people eagerly look forward to
this next season of Demon Slayer this
time we take to the swordsmith Village
as danjiro heads to said Village to get
his sword repaired however demons close
in and missed pilotokito finds himself
facing off against not one but two upper
moons he'd need help from tanjiro and
the returning genya but with their
combined strength be enough to defeat
both demons especially with a foe with
such Troublesome ability that makes
itself nigh impossible to kill the
sequel to Demas there was all but
guaranteed given the Smashing success
that the series continued to enjoy I'm
beginning to see the road to a fun
adaptation to be honest demonstrator
promises you multiple things God the
animation exciting fights full of hype
moments and a simple yet very
captivating plot to keep you wanting
more I've been a fan of the swordsmith
arc as a manga reader so this is one of
my personal my favorites heading into
the season I'm sure a lot of fans agree
with me on that one but why is
demaslayer only second on this list hmm
it did fall in the same season as
become a running joke at this point with
me and my friends on how they keep
splitting the attack on Titan finale
into halves not that I blame the team
since I want to make this to the best of
their abilities and it gives some good
openings for discussion I mean some
people have already been talking about a
possible anime original ending and if
the big brain plan is to keep
discussions in series presence rolling
it's working like a charm where a decade
and over four seasons in so it's hard to
talk about this season of Attack on
Titan without delving too much into
spoiler territory however I will say
this Attack on Titan has become one of
the anime that's defined the 2020s and
for good reason too it's about time you
catch up on it if you showed even the
slightest bit of Interest it goes
through different types of genres with
an engaging overarching story and strong
themes and it's hit a home run on a lot
of those plots so far the manga ending
may have been polarizing but it's
something that you've got to see for
good reason Attack on Titan is what I
think is the most anticipated anime
coming this spring
whatever
see you there do you think that attack
on Titan is the most anticipated title
this spring 2023 I'd have to get your
feedback and your thoughts on the list
I'm also open for suggestions on
possible lists that the team can look
into in the future so don't forget to
write those down as comments if you want
to once again I'm grateful to you thanks
for watching and staying all the way to
the end and I wish you a great day ahead